faute de se faire entendre par les
responsables politiques de la plupart
des pays du monde les experts
scientifiques multiplie les alertes et
les scénarios catastrophes à propos du
réchauffement de la terre dans les
décennies à venir les catastrophes
naturelles pourrait être de plus en plus
importante commenté ramier ce monteur et
qu'il n' dernier -50° en mongolie depuis
plus de quatre mois
1 millions d'animaux sont morts de froid
et 300000 mongol risque la famille dans
d'autres régions notamment en afrique
la sécheresse qui menace les populations
des sécheresses qui se multiplieront au
cours du 21e siècle
le climat change de plus en plus
brutalement la fonte des glaciers au
pôle sud en est le principal témoignage
ce glacier a perdu 10 mètres de hauteur
en sept ans
les experts internationaux scrute le
climat depuis dix ans il prévoit une
augmentation de 2 à 6 degrés d'ici un
siècle avec des conséquences à venir
extrême multiplication des tempêtes et
des ouragans et surtout augmentation des
inondations en afrique et en asie les
pays les moins développés souffriront le
plus du réchauffement climatique
depuis dix ans les conférences se
multiplient quelques décisions pour
limiter les gaz à effet de serre ont été
prises à kyoto japon
mais encore faudrait-il qu'elle soit
appliquée pour l'instant monde cherche à
faire comment il pourrait faire pour
essayer on pratique de ne pas tenir les
engagements qu'il a pris à kyoto et donc
c'est quand même un petit peu décevant
c'est vrai dès la semaine prochaine les
experts proposeront des solutions pour
limiter le réchauffement des solutions
que les états connaissent déjà par
exemple le développement des énergies
renouvelables
mais aujourd'hui en france les éoliennes
et les capteurs solaires produisent à
peine 1% de l'électricité